ça ça ça ça ou encore ça et si tout ça
n'existait pas salut c'est Lucas la
question qu'on va se poser dans ce
nouvel épisode elle vient d'une
discussion avec mon collègue Sébastien
avec toutes les discussions parfois
agitées qui peuvent exister sur la
question du véganisme on s'est demandé
mais au fond qu'est-ce que ça changerait
concrètement si tout le monde était
végan j'ai donc cherché à répondre à
deux questions principales quelles
seraient les conséquences pour
l'agriculture et la alimentation
qu'est-ce que ça changerait concrètement
pour la planète et les animaux je vous
explique avant de voir très vite
certaines conséquences possibles il faut
qu'on parle de la même chose si tout le
monde était végan ou végétalien ce
serait un refus de la chair animale mais
aussi de tous les produits issus des
animaux comme les œufs le lait et donc
le fromage et le yaourt par exemple donc
si tout le monde arrêter de manger tout
produit issu des animaux que pourrai
devenir les animaux en
question
selon les derniers chiffres de la FAO
dans le monde l'élevage représente près
d'un milliard de cochons 1,7 milliards
de vaches et de buffles 2,4 milliards de
chèvres et moutons et 25,9 milliards de
poules et poulet dans un monde végan par
définition ces animaux ne seraient plus
élevés et abattus pour l'agriculture
mais pour qu'ils continue à exister je
me suis demandé si on pouvait imaginer
les relâcher en liberté dans la
nature
ce sont bien spè sauement est d'accord
uneévolution depu la mise en place de
l'agriculture la ressource manger PIR
boire et donc ça devient l'équilibre
devs compqu dans certains
exemples chevaux par exemple des débats
autour des chevaux relâchés il y en a
notamment en Australie je vous en avais
parl dans une autre vidéo et je vous
mets le lien en description youtube il
est donc probable que la plupart de ces
espèces issues de l'élevage soit
déséquilibre des écosystèmes soit
finissent par
disparaître une altertive ça pourrait
être de mettre en place des programmes
et des espaces pour garder ces animaux
dans de bonnes conditions comme il n'y
aurait plus d'élevage et qu'on devrait
récupérer des terres pour faire pousser
des substituts aux produits animaux les
populations de ces animaux diminueraient
fortement on serait donc bien loin des
milliards d'animaux d'élevage qu'on a
aujourd'hui cela réduirait la biomasse
totale des mammifères c'est-à-dire leur
poids cumulé celle-ci est constituée
aujourd'hui de 34 % d'humains de 62 %
d'animaux d'élevage et de seulement 4 %
d'animaux
sauvages même chose pour la biomasse
totale des oiseaux qui sont à 71 %
composés de poulets et d'autres oiseaux
d'élevage mais il n'y a pas que
l'élevage qu'en serait-il pour tous les
animaux qui sont aujourd'hui soit
chassés soit pêchés pour être mangés
d'abord pour des espèces invasives ou
pour des animaux qui n'ont plus assez de
prédateur naturel et bien on peut
imaginer qu'il se multiplierait
localement et pourrait entraîner des
dégâts ça pourrait nécessiter des moyens
de régulation et des moyens donc
différents de la chasse puisque le
véganisme exclut de tuer des animaux à
l'inverse il y a beaucoup d'autres
animaux qui sont actuellement menacés
soit par la surpêche comme le ton obèse
soit par la chasse comme le pangolin ou
les Goris par exemple on peut imaginer
im que la plupart de ces populations
réaugmenteraiit progressivement et donc
s'éloignerait de l'extinction c'est ce
qui s'est passé par exemple dans une
réserve en Nouvelle-Calédonie où la
pêche a été totalement interdite des
scientifiques qui ont constaté une
augmentation de près de 67 % des espèces
de poissons consommables en à peine 4
ans ça ce serait pour les animaux mais
plus globalement pour l'agriculture ce
serait tout un système à
repenser en gros j'ai voulu savoir si
dans ce monde sans élevage on pouvait
imaginer nourrir le monde de manière
durable j'ai notamment posé cette
question à deux scientifiques lui c'est
Marco springman il a fait plusieurs
études qui mettent en avant des régimes
avec moins de viande y compris végan et
lui c'est Philippe lesquat il travaille
sur le rôle de l'élevage et pour lui un
monde végan comporterait de nombreuses
limites il y a trois possibilités en
fait par rapport à ça c'est le
remplacement le remplacement par des
matières premières végétales classiques
peut transformer c'est très vertuueux he
c'est l'usage des dentilles des poisss
le deuxième point c'est l'ultr
transansformation pour euh imiter
finalement leséines que l'on mange
actuellement ça en effet c'est un
processus quie plusieurs problèmes que
so des problèmes de santé des problèmes
énergéques et trè la trè question qui
est souventosé auss c'est de synthèse et
cette synèse il est très probable
qu'elle s'appuie sur de
l'Our aujourd'hui dans le monde un peu
Mo tiers des terres agricoles sont des
cultures qui servent à nourrir les
humains et une partie des
animaux à côté de ces culture un peu
plus des de tiers des terres agricoles
sont des pâturages où vivent et se
nourrissent une partie des vaches des
moutons ou des chèvres par exemple dans
un scénario où tout le monde serait
végan est-ce que les terres libérées par
l'élevage seraient suffisantes pour
faire pousser assez de plantes pour
nourrir tout le monde l'exemple typique
hein c'est quand on est en montagne et
alors qu'on est une certaine aptitude on
ne peut plus parcousser de céréales donc
de toute façon le seul usage ce sont
déc part of it we would of courseuse to
grow
otherood because so much that we feed
animals we would also have net saving
there about you know 10% of of land use
which might not sound so much but if you
put that all together it's theen j'ai
trouvé plusieurs autres études qui
concluent aussi à une réduction des
terres utilisées dans le d'un scénario
100 % végétal selon cette étude de 2018
cela pourrait libérer tous les pâturages
et on utiliserait seulement 80 % environ
des cultures actuelles alors ça ce sont
des estimations mondiales ça veut pas
forcément dire que ça se passerait comme
ça dans chaque pays certains ont
beaucoup de prairies et peu de terr
cultivables ce qui veut dire qu'il
devrai augmenter leurs importations par
exemple j'ai trouvé d'autres études qui
pointent certaines limites que pourra
avoir ce modèle sans élevage par exemple
cette étude de 2017 a imaginé ce
changement pour les États-Unis elle
indique d'abord qu'un mod d'agriculture
végétale pourrait produire 23 % de
nourriture en plus mais que cette
production pourrait répondre à une part
insuffisante des besoins de la
population américaine en nutriment
essentiel à l'inverse Marco springman
m'a indiqué qu'un monde végan associé à
des régimes plus équilibrés pouvait
contribuer à des améliorations en teres
de santé publique tout en reconnaissant
certains
obstacles
pour ce modèle agricole aurait d'autres
limites fragilité et les
CHS
bien
AG 100% V impqu de prof transformation
des mod agol enjeux techniqu économi et
nutritionnels qui pourrai être différent
d'un endroit à l'autre mais j'ai
découvert que cela pourrait aussi
entraîner d'importants changements pour
l'environnement et le
climat déjà reprenons ces préies qui se
retrouverai théoriquement sans animaux
je me suis demandé ce qu' pourrait
devenir si on enlève les animaux
domestique d'un grand nombre d'espaces
pr et bien ces espaces dans la plupart
des cas se referm on va avoir aussi une
disparition de certains espac les maris
deviendra des
marur plus d'entretien par pour garder
les écosystèmes de certaines prairies en
bonne santé ces deux scientifique
s'accorde sur la nécessité d'y conserver
certains animaux
d'élevage
en l'absence de revenu lié à la vente de
viande et de lait cela nécessiterait de
trouver d'importants moyens pour
organiser et financer ce maintien
regardons maintenant du côté du climat
aujourd'hui l'agriculture représente
entre 1/4 et un/ers du total des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre selon
la FAO Rin don les bovin les et les
Cerin comme il mange de l'herbe ou il
mange des fibres et en fait il les
dégrade dans la poche gastique principal
et en faisant cela ils émettent du CO2
et du méthane et le méthane est un gaz à
effet de ser particulièrement puissant
les Pors et les volailles qui sont quand
même les deux viandes et les deux types
d'animaux les plus mangés au monde et de
loin et bien là ces animauxl vont
utiliser les cultures qui ont nécessité
pour être fait de l'énergie et qui donc
ont produit des gaz àp de ser aussi if
we all became vegan we would be able to
save roughly 8 gigatons of CO2
equivalence per year
l'étude sur les États-Unis dont je vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure abouti à une
baisse moins élevée car selon elle une
agriculture sans animaux nécessiterait
d'autres transformations dont on n pas
encore parlé il faudrait par exemple
éliminer les résidus que les humains
donnaient avant aux animaux c'est-à-dire
les déchets de certaines cultures que
l'on donne à manger à certains élevages
il faudrait aussi produire des engrais
de synthèse pour remplacer le fumier
animal au final elle montre que le
passage à une agriculture végane aux
États-Unis entraînerait quand même une
baisse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mais de seulement 28 %. on va
utiliser beaucoup plus d'énergie fossile
pour produire les ressources don on à
travers la mécanisation et à travers
l'usage d' de synthèse puisque on ne
disposera plus de de fier de et donc il
est peut-être probable d'avoir deénergie
solaire ou bien sûr ch renouvelable mais
mais dans le cadre là au bon mais alors
ça donnerait quoi cette étude de 2016
elle a essayé de trancher en compilant
toutes les études qui avait été faite
jusque- là sur le modèle véan le
résultat il montre une baisse des
émissions plus probablement situé entre
- 35 % et - 55 % par rapport au régime
moyen actuel et qu'en est-il des autres
impacts sur l'environnement cette étude
faite par des scientifiques Croates en
2022 indique qu'un monde 100 % végan
pourrait compromettre les ressources en
eau et en terre ainsi que la
biodiversité notamment du fait des
engrais chimiques de synthèse et aussi
du besoin accru en irrigation ce
résultat sur l'eau il m'a étonné parce
que j'avais en tête que la production de
bœuf par exemple consommait beaucoup
plus d'eau que les alternatives
végétales mais des études ont montré que
ramené à des quantités de protéines
équivalent le poulet pouvait consommer
moins d'eau que des haricots ou des noix
par
exemple water foint
hasement
un monde végan entraînerait donc une
amélioration assez certaine pour le
climat et l'occupation des sols et en
fonction des alternatives retenues il
pourrait présenter des risques sur
d'autres enjeux environnementaux comme
l'eau ok pour ce scénario 100 % végan
mais qu'est-ce que ça donne par rapport
à d'autres options qui existent pour
réduire l'impact de
[Musique]
l'agriculture à partir de 63 études des
chercheurs ont comp Comper les impacts
environnementaux de différents régimes
par rapport aux habitudes alimentaires
actuelles voici par exemple les gains
qu'on peut espérer sur le climat avec un
régime végan mais aussi végétarien un
régime pécéarien donc sans viande mais
avec du poisson et des fruits de mer un
régime plus équilibré avec moins de
viande un régime méditerranéen avec
notamment moins de viande mais plus de
poissons et de légumes ou alors en
remplaçant les ruminants donc le bœuf et
le mouton par exemple par d'autres
animaux comme les volailles ou le cochon
ces bandes sur le graphique c'est pour
englober tous les résultats des
différentes études qui peuvent parfois
un peu différer ici plus un scénario est
à gauche plus l'impact sur le climat est
faible on peut voir que les régimes avec
le moins de viandes sont les plus
avantagés voici maintenant les résultats
sur l'eau selon cette étude on voit que
sur ce point le régime végan pourrait
être bien moins optimisé que d'autres
dans ce caslà particulier le scénario
végan il y avait une seule étude qui
l'avait modélisé et donc le résultat est
à prendre avec un peu plus de pincettes
et voici enfin les résultats en terme
d'occupation des terres les meilleurs
résultats sont globalement ceux qui
comportent beaucoup moins de viande the
big challenges is not to exceed Socalled
planetary boundaries right and climate
change is one such planetary boundary
but also biodiversity loss and in our
research on that we found that going
completely plantbased would help even
more but if everybody changed and we
also had some changes in the way we
produce foods then a flexitarian diet
would work as well with low amounts of
animal sourcees résultats généraux il
peuvent varier dans des cas particuliers
en fon par exemple des aliments précis
qu'on choisir et de la manière dont ils
sont produit on doit dans chacun de ces
territoires essayer de travailler avec
les agriculteurs mais aussi avec les
personnes qui vivent dans ce territoire
pour trouver les équilibres donc ça veut
dire que il n'y a pas de recette unique
plus largement en effet devenir végan ou
produire moins de viande ne sont pas les
seuls facteurs qui peuvent réduire
l'impact de l'agriculture sur les
animaux ou l'environnement par exemple
plusieurs travaux du CNRS montrent que
planter des arbres avec les cultures
passer à l'agriculture biologique ou à
l'agroécologie ou encore mieux
préservver les sols peut apporter
d'autres bénéfices pour l'environnement
du côté de l'impact sur le climat le GC
a compilé les tonnes de gaz à effet de
serre qu'on pourrait éviter d'ici 2030
avec différentes solutions on y retrouve
la transition vers des régimes dit
duraes et équilibré avec une baisse
significative de la viande de ruminant
notamment mais aussi d'autres solutions
lutter contre le gaspillage alimentaire
réduire le méthane et le protoxyde
d'azote dans l'agriculture par exemple
en changeant l'alimentation des bovins
ou en réduisant certains engrais de
synthèse stocker plus plus de carbone
dans l'agriculture notamment grâce à
l'agroforesterie ou à une meilleure
gestion des prairies ou encore arrêter
de détruire des espaces naturels pour
les
exploiter c'est-à-dire arrêter la
déforestation pour l'urbanisation
l'élevage la production d'huile végétale
ou de biocarburant par exemple en 2020
une enquête de France agrimaire estimée
à 0,3 % la part d'adultes végétaliens ou
végan en France s environ 115000
personnes dans plusieurs pays il existe
un attachement social culturel ou
économique fort avec avec l'élevage ou
des produits qui en sont issu et un
grand nombre d'agriculteurs ou d'autres
métiers en dépendent dans cette vidéo
l'objectif c'est pas de vous dire si
c'est bien ou mal de devenir végane ou
de manger de la viande et je trouvve
intéressant de faire cette expérience de
pensée notamment pour mieux comprendre
ce qui pouvait avoir du poids sur
l'environnement ou le climat évidemment
je ne mets pas dans cette solution là
mais d'avoir ce scénario cette
expérience de pensée me permet de dire
mais pourquoi j'ai besoin de C êre beau
pourquoi je peux en avoir beaucoup moins
pourquoi je dois en avoir beaucoup plus
dans certains pays donc ça m'aide à
repenser l'équilibre
happen people adop complely plas di is
basic something that provid sort of in a
way a cornerstone in the road to see
okay we could go there uh yes we might
not make it there but this is a
possibility and every single person who
wonders about their diets can think if
they would get Go completely plantbased
versus maybe adopting let's say
flexitarian
diet
dans cette vidéo on n bien sûr pas du
tout pu tout traiter si vous êtes
agriculteur scientifique ou que vous
avez travailler sur ce sujets d'une
manière ou d'une autre n'hésitez pas à
compléter dans les commentaires
notamment en parlant des enjeux de santé
d'économie ou plein d'autres choses et
si vous avez juste envie de nous
partager votre avis sur le sujet
n'hésitez pas on n pas beaucoup parlé de
santé mais j'ai aussi posé la question à
mes interlocuteurs on peut se nourrir
sans prier de mot hein ça c'est c'est
une réalité maintenant sur des
populations fragiles les enfants
personnes agé fmes enceintes on dans les
situations de de déficit qui quand même
quasi
obligatoireage de Protin anim pas du
tout auveauu auour'hui dans les pays
déveloésan powerful in reducing diet
related risks so you wouldn't have the
risk factors of high and process meat
but I should also say there is always
concern if on complely plas di thatbe
little B B vitamins like B12 and calcium
can be a little bit low as well if you
have a nutritional deficiency the first
point of action would be try to re to
change the composition for example have
more green leafy vegetables in your diet
to get plenty of iron um and as a second
step you could see if you supplement it
with with vitamins mineral vous pouvez
liker la vidéo si elle vous a plu et
retrouver d'autres épisodes de la grande
explication et d'autres vidéos sur la
chaîne de brut on se retrouve dimanche
prochain pour un nouvel épisode et je
vous dis à
[Musique]
bientôt